so you're looking live at capitol hill
secretary of state anthony blinken in
the hot seat testifying before the house
foreign affairs committee on the chaotic
exit from afghanistan which left
americans behind about a hundred of them
we'll continue to monitor that for any
breaking news meantime lawmakers on both
sides of the aisle are getting their
first chance to hold the
administration's feet to the fire over
what went wrong here's what the
secretary said in his opening statement
it was time to end america's longest war
there's no evidence that staying longer
would have made the afghan security
forces
or the afghan government any more
resilient or self-sustaining
if 20 years
and hundreds of billions of dollars in
support equipment and training did not
suffice
why would another year another five
another ten we expect the taliban to
ensure freedom of travel
to make good on his commitments on
counter-terrorism
to uphold the basic rights of the afghan
people
and republicans pressing the secretary
on whether the department blocked any
americans from leaving
did state at any point in the evacuation
process block american citizens from
leaving afghanistan
no we did not none your testimony before
congress is that state didn't block any
american citizens leaving africa
contrary my officers men and women ran
into the building from around the world
to help them it's a simple yes or no i
hope you do it with mr connelly you can
do it with me yes or no
i just want to clarify
you didn't block anybody state didn't
block any americans no they were there
to help america
all right pete let me start with you um
the the accountability for this is what
was going to be in question for quite a
while even though it was only 30
about 30 days since uh this all started
going down in afghanistan in terms of
really down it feels like even over the
weekend
that everything had changed in terms of
the war on terror like do people feel
safer and we're going to talk about
democrats also being frustrated and
worried and leon panetta was just wrong
with neil cavuto we'll have that for you
in just a little bit you know he was
very critical and said the president
ought to admit mistakes you should and a
lot of us spent the weekend reflecting
on where we are considering where we
were 20 years ago and you can't deny the
fact that we're in a more dangerous and
precarious situation and you can't deny
the fact that that uh tony blinken spent
the time testifying he effectively was
trying to defend the indefensible he's
still he's still doing that right now
there's no way to defend what he said
what the administration said they would
do and square it with the actions of
what occurred in kabul from from what he
can oversee to the abandoning the
embassy which he said he would never
ever do to claiming in that clip you
played that they were not blocking
americans from leaving afghanistan which
those of us who were involved in that
effort know that it's
categorically false
uh every scene do you think that's why
he was trying to be so careful in the
way he answered that well he
he was but he ultimately said no
no we rushed into the buildings no we
were we were there to facilitate no you
blocked people at every single turn and
you could never answer the actual
questions as far as the number of people
so give or take 100 americans green card
holders thousands of them siv we're
vetting them as they go through the
process but we don't actually know
whether there's a big difference between
siv applicants who have been vetted
through a process and at-risk afghans
who were hoarded onto an airfield at the
last minute with very little vetting and
the what the information we're getting
so far is that most of the people that
made it through are not siv holders so
that process is going to unravel and
it's all because what he said was true i
mean he said in march
the administration would bring a
responsible end to the conflict that we
would remove troops from harm's way
which of course we didn't know we know
those 13 names and ensure that
afghanistan never became a haven for
terrorists and now the talib many of the
taliban who were in charge at 9 11 are
now in charge now and they were
exchanged uh for bergdahl for the five
of the
the taliban terrorists are in taliban
leadership and you know how anthony
blinken uh describes it they have a very
challenging track record
the state department never let you down
in terms of the way to speak um there
was a lot of blaming by democrats uh
they tried to blame president trump uh
we have a little bit of sound watch this
where was the protest when the trump
administration negotiated a deal with
the taliban how meticulous was the
planning for the trump administration
declared may first withdrawal
thank you congressman uh we uh we
inherited a deadline we did not inherit
a plan so
nope uh no plan at all among those 5 000
people released with the consent
and negotiated agreement of the trump
administration i guess our concern about
terrorists is pretty selective
jesse your thoughts well that's why they
didn't really lay a glove on blinken
because democrats protect them and the
republicans don't ask the right
questions the republicans today needed
to zero in on what biden and his team
were saying publicly and how that wasn't
really
the truth if you compare it to the
embassy cables the intelligence
briefings the facts on the ground the
phone call between joe and the afghan
president that's the nexus of the
scandal that's the dereliction of duty
that's where the lies lay that's where
the cover-up was
but they don't ask the right questions
and that's why we're going to run mr
hegseth for congress so we could get on
the committee and ask the right question
five minutes we did find out that he has
no clue how many americans are still
there and the taliban is still blocking
things we found out basically that putin
booted joe biden from central asia so we
don't have any basing rights to give us
that as he loves to say over the horizon
capability
it actually seems like the fbi
interviewed blink and about the hunter
biden criminal probe
that slipped out during the hearing so
attaboy republicans there but the guy
was so boring and that was the strategy
and you know dana i don't like to make
personal attacks i know you don't
you made a new year's resolution you've
really held too but he is like the
elevator music of empty suits right he
is so boring paint watches him dry
i tried because i couldn't follow
putting the subtitles up on the tv the
tv wouldn't even do that
okay it's like when the dog whistles
humans can't hear it i swear to god the
guy's cadence it's like a mortician
combined with a podiatrist and a hostage
negotiator it just kind of washes over
you even the members of congress who
i've never seen because they're so
boring they can't get booked on cable
they were more compelling than anthony
blinken but that's the strategy bore you
to death while everybody else dies if
rookie can whistle i want to see that
exactly um one of the things that
anthony blinken said in his opening
statement was that um
he basically kept saying if we had
stayed longer that it wasn't like the
afghan army was going to be
able to sustain but that really wasn't
the question that that wasn't they're
trying to to focus on the the idea that
americans want us out of afghanistan
that's what a lot of people have
campaigned on including president trump
and president joe biden that's not the
point and also let's not forget that
president biden and we've said this
number of times in july said that
there's no way that the afghan army is
going to get run over that the taliban
will take over the country and well here
we are so when he you know throws up his
hands and says we didn't know this was
going to happen nobody knew they did
know and the president lied to the
country about it i want to focus on what
he said too when he said we inherited a
deadline we did not inherit a plan
they're trying to rewrite history here
to focus on leaving afghanistan this
administration pushed the deadline from
may which was a trump deadline to
september to the fighting period when
the taliban under 11 to september 11th
right
to the fighting period where the taliban
was going to be stronger which is why
they marched all over afghanistan
instead of you know being able to get
out in may
they say that they were just executing
president trump's plan in the last
couple of weeks with the chaos but now
he's saying that he wasn't given a plan
so which one is it uh we also saw that
him say in april that he wanted to
withdraw responsibly deliberately and
safely that didn't happen i was on the
plane in february of 2020 when the
secretary of state mike pompeo released
the framework for this agreement with
the taliban which was also an agreement
that the taliban and the afghani
government had to work together there
were conditions we killed taliban
leaders if they
were involved in any kind of violence we
went 18 months with zero u.s casualties
in afghanistan
we just had 13 american service members
killed many of them wounded and
americans were left behind and so this
idea now that they're going to say well
we didn't have a plan but if we had a
plan it was trump's plan and by the way
you know this is none of our our fault
and we didn't know this was going to
happen and we're going to rewrite
history on what the trump administration
implemented in terms of conditions and
getting out of the country in a
successful responsible way uh it's it's
definitely a tactic because they're
trying to focus on the other to that
point there's a great interview that
trey gowdy did on his podcast with cash
patel if you want any more information
on that i encourage you to listen to
that one this is not the only hearing
jessica there's another one tomorrow and
apparently the senate democrats are
saying they don't want to focus on the
last 30 days they want to focus on the
last 20 years
yes it'll be a quick one then you know
just a few hours of chat um
it read like most of these hearings
usually read you only get five minutes
to ask questions everyone wants to get
in like a couple pot shots at the person
if they're of the opposing party
uh get their cable news sound bites so
jesse waters knows who they are
and then move on with their day but i
did notice i mean it was pretty equal
opportunity criticism congresswoman
karen bass
went pretty hard at him about the
humanitarian issues are there
protections in place for women and girls
david cicellini from rhode island lgbtqi
people what is going on these are
at-risk people in these communities who
are being left behind from us that was
one of the central pledges of what joe
biden and frankly every american
president always says which is that
human rights matter and we know
from just what's gone on the past few
weeks that they obviously don't to the
taliban um i think that lincoln did
a totally fine job and that people's
hearts and minds on this won't be moved
they approve of the decision they don't
like the withdrawal it's bipartisan
well to that end we are keeping an eye
on the secretary of state uh anthony
blinken he's testifying on capitol hill
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else